thank you
good afternoon and welcome to this
performance governance and audit
committee meeting on thursday the 24th
of september
2020 my name is councillor elaine
bamford
and i'm the chairman of this committee
um you'll have to bear with me because
i'm not in the best of health
my voice is a bit dodgy so
bear with me so this meeting is held on
new regulations which came into effect
on the fourth of april in response to
the kovid 19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through first of all
please could i ask everyone present in
this meeting to ensure your microphone
remains muted
and your video feed off when not
addressing
the committee this will reduce
background noises and avoid any
unintentional disturbances the meeting
is being hosted remotely streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
i would then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminded
that apart from indicating you wish to
speak or that you have to leave the
meeting
the chat function should only be used
for questions
and not any other purpose please do not
use the raise hand function is that is
not available
on all members devices when speaking and
referring to the agenda papers please
ensure
you reference a page or paragraph number
and last if members need to leave the
meeting at any point please do make this
known and use the trunk
chat function to signify that you need
to leave the meeting
now may i ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with um mr dodson please
good afternoon paul dodson director of
strategy performance and governance
thank you ms donnelly
video and internal order manager we do
we don't oh yes issues
yeah thank you um
dominic gellar
sorry that's damian geller i'm sorry
i just got dominic on my prompt
sorry about that specialist community
mr holmes
good afternoon richard holm with
structural service delivery
ms hughes
good afternoon um cheryl hughes programs
performance and governance manager
chris leslie director of resources
mr rubins greg rubins from bdo
internal audit thank you welcome
and miss sangee lee
noto i don't know whether i pronounce
that correctly i'm sorry if i haven't
uh good afternoon azaria sangalimu to
external audit manager
okay thank you very much welcome um mr
wisdom
uh craig wisdom from deloitte excellent
partner
thank you welcome and berna
good afternoon members bernie casey
clark to the meeting
and do we have any other members
sorry any other offices present
not that i can see no okay thank you
very much bernard
um now berna could you now carry out a
roll call of members to confirm who is
in attendance thank you
thank you chairman
members i will call your name in
alphabetical order
um starting with councillor bamford well
i'm here thank you benner
thank you council b.s bill
president good afternoon councillor mrs
channel
uh president berna good afternoon
everyone thank you
counselor durham uh good afternoon all
good afternoon berna present
thank you cancer heard
good afternoon bernard and colleagues
present
councillor jarvis
president bernie good afternoon thank
you cancer keys
caster keys i know we have him he was
sorry
he's here president good afternoon
yes thank you master keys counseling
uh present bernar thank you very much
good afternoon
thank you councillor stilts
good afternoon burner present thank you
council swain
yes better good afternoon here can you
cancel
mrs thompson
yes i'm i'm present thank you bernard
good afternoon everyone
thank you members chairman could i ask
any other members in attendance to
please introduce themselves now
good afternoon and welcome thank you
councillor morris
anybody else good afternoon it's uh
ann hall councillor hall thank you very
much councilman hall
thank you thank you chairman
okay uh move on to apologies for absence
thank you um so then members we go on to
the minutes of the 30th of july
2020. um pound on pages 5 to 12.
um so i just need you to approve these
as a true and accurate ref
record um do you want me to go through
page by page or are you happy for me to
take them
take it on block happy for on block
chairman um
unless anyone's got any issues but
approve them agree
agreed thompson agreed everyone's happy
okay lovely so we'll take those
as accepted thank you um
declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph six to
eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they also
require to disclose any such interest as
soon as they become aware
should the needs arise throughout the
meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat
function to indicate and i'll invite you
to speak
so um have we got anyone berna yes
counselor channel
councillor channel go ahead counselor
thank you yes
yes i used both actually okay all right
yeah i did chat and hand just to make
sure because with the toolbar in the new
place um
yes just to advise madam chairman
non-pecuniary
um i'm also a member of essex county
council
and um there's several items where
there's reference in with things that
actually do link with essex such as the
flooding
and um suds is mentioned as well so
bearing in mind the involvement and the
direction and they mentioned planning
in one of the things about what we might
not be doing but as essex certainly does
with the authority um and anywhere else
on the agenda where essex might have a
link or as mentioned madam chairman
thank you thank you thank you
anyone else benner councillor durham has
his hand up
yeah i apologize my chat is not working
it's
okay all right well we look out for your
hand although it's not really accepted
but there we go
inside of that or nothing or me
interrupting german i apologize
um uh yes as a non-binary interest as a
member of essex county council for the
same reasons has
been explained by councillor china thank
you
thank you councillor don um anyone else
berna
no no okay good so we move on to
a public participation i can advise that
we've not received any submissions from
members of the public
so we move on to item six which is the
internal audit reports
there are progress follow-up
recommendations corporate governance and
flooding risk
management um
so again members if you wish to speak
please use the chat function and keep
your points
referring to the page number if possible
so we have with us greg rubins
from internal audit bdo and he'll
present
the progress report and the follow-up
recommendations report
thank you mr rubins thank you so
um the progress report i'll just talk to
page 17 of your papers
um you'll see that we are presenting two
reports today they're the last two
reports from the 1920 program so that
concludes that
and we have a number of um audits
underway for this current year
so obviously it was a slow start because
of covid but we'll be catching up
and as long as we can continue working
we will
complete the program um just to say in
terms of the audits the list of audits
we will be doing two pieces of advisory
work
this year one is related to your fraud
risk assessment
and you might remember that there were
some actions um to follow up on that and
provide some training and support
so we'll continue to do that and we will
update the fraud risk assessment as well
and secondly is uh some work in relation
to
um accounting standard ifrs 16 which is
to do with the accounting for leases
we will be providing some training and
support to officers
as part of that so that won't end up
with an audit report but it will be
part of our internal audit work to
support the council
i'll now move on to the follow-up and
i'll take questions on the two reports
together
so the follow-up report actually takes
us to
september so it is current i think it
says in the covering paper
february but it is actually september so
this is the latest position
um and you'll see that we've been able
to sign two
recommendations offers completed and
there is only one recommendation that is
yet to be completed
and that relates to your waste strategy
which is now being incorporated into
your new
climate strategy so once that is
completed we should be able to
sign that recommendation off as well um
so i would say
you know good progress in terms of
implementing recommendations
um so as promised i'll pause at this
point take any questions on the
progress report and follow up report and
then after that
we'll talk through the two detailed
reports that are contained in your
papers
on corporate governance and flood
management
okay thank you um so berna have we got
anyone who wants to speak on
either internal audit or the progress
report please
yes heard swain and none
okay i just speak so counselor
um could you just say when you ask your
question what um report you're
you're asking your question about please
yes thank you chairman uh i'm referring
to appendix 2 which is on
page 26. um
so i'll start with that i'll start with
that one
it's talking about a fraud risk
assessment
and the council should commission
external resources to develop etc
i see this is down as a high priority
and i welcome of course uh
uh further training on that but can i
can i ask
how many cases of fraud have we actually
identified since the first of january
that's my first question uh the second
part
is on the next page page 27
i'm hoping that somebody can help me
with
some words which appear to be missing
because
where it's got recommendations overdue
it says
create and environmental and waste
management strategy
and also on the other side where it says
current progress
it looks as though some words have been
missed out there
because it says waste strategy has been
replaced by climate change strategy
has been taken over by the new lead
community officer i'm not quite sure
what that means uh the next one i've got
is on page
32
which speaks about um
the key findings this is mainly to do
with the overview and scrutiny
and the effectiveness of that committee
and also what i'd like to ask
is about whether or not these
the number of cancelled committees
are justifiable thank you
thank you councillor um mr rubins
would you be able to answer those
questions please
um i'll be able to answer one of them
i'm afraid well but i'll explain why i
can't answer the other two
um so the first one um uh i the one that
i can answer is relating to the
um missing words um so
um apologies it's not perhaps as clear
as it could be so this is
on page 27
so when it says the recommendation was
to create it should say
an a.n rather than and so hopefully that
explains that
and then obviously the the progress
which is provided by the council
uh means that the waste strategy has
been replaced by climate change strategy
and this has been taken over by the new
lead community officer
to finalize the draft version so just a
couple of missing words
there um in terms of the um
corporate governance report if you don't
mind can we wait until emma has
presented
that report and then we'll take
questions on that report so we'll we'll
we'll confirm then
and the last question was the number of
fraud cases
uh i don't have that information i mean
we're obviously um
looking at your current fraud strategy
that would be one for officers to
respond to so i don't know whether the
um section 151 officer would be able to
to answer that one thank you i think
he's indicated that he can do so
um so um mr leslie would you like to
just answer the
fraud question please yes of course
the dwp actually took over a lot of the
fraud work around
housing benefits so they've been
covering that
so aside from housing benefits and
council tax benefits uh don't have those
uh numbers but in terms of actually
other types of fraud activity
in terms of supply forward payments
employee forward etcetera
i've uh i'm not aware of any uh
of those sort of fruit activities taking
place so
actually the amount of food is very low
and non-existent in the
in the other areas
[Music]
is that answering your questions
counselor heard i know you asked a
question about overview and scrutiny but
i think we all know
the reason why that committee hasn't met
is from
lack of business that's what we've been
advised but anyway
um on your other two points have the mr
rubins
and um mr lee leslie answered your
questions
well i'm grateful for the clarification
of the wording
uh and uh maybe that's something i i
should have seen but i was rather
confused by it
um no i think
in relation to um to the
to the other point uh i wondered why it
was a high priority then if
if fraud is as low as it is why is it
such a high priority isn't there other
things we could be getting on with
please mr leslie could you
clarify that or mr rubens
i'm happy to to talk about that because
we agreed at the time
um that it was high priority because it
is a requirement on councils to have
an up-to-date fraud strategy and an
action plan
to address that strategy is actually a
regulatory requirement
so and we considered that to be high
priority because
you at the time you had nothing in place
you do now have
some arrangements in place so it
certainly isn't high at the moment and
in fact we believe
the council's taking the right action to
address that recommendation
okay thank you very much you're happy
with that thank you councillor head
um councillor swain i think was next who
had some questions
internal order or the follow-up
follow on ones on some flood risk
management
um well we haven't got onto those yet um
that's just internal audit and follow-up
recommendations at the moment
so i will call you when we go over the
other reports
um mr uh councillor none
did you have some questions thank you
very much yes i do can i take you please
to page
25.
um it says that whilst
i'm noting that community safety
recommendations are not due until
october
but we're nearly in october in fact it's
next week
can we be reassured that that uh area
will be ready for implementation
okay is that your only question no my
second question relates to page 32
all right on page 32
uh the internal audit corporate
governance
is quite critical of committees
and their effectiveness and of member
training
and i'm just curious to know what
methodology was used to establish that
uh
that opinion uh how on earth do the
auditors know about
individual member skills for example
because
unless other people tell me otherwise i
don't ever remember being
interviewed about any skill base
okay thank you um i i
take it this is mainly an officer
question
um mr rubens is it something you could
answer
um well again i think we we haven't
presented that report yet but but if you
if you're asking me about it we if you
look at the detailed findings they're
mainly around
the structure that you have in place um
and
whether you have the right training um
so we're not saying that members don't
have the right skills we're just saying
that it isn't formalized in terms of
what training you do have uh and how
it's provided so
um you know i i think we were within our
rights to
point that out um and obviously we do
compare you to other councils as well
in terms of the sort of structures and
support we'd expect to see in place
okay thank you um the first question
counselor none
related to the first question
about communities community safety
regulations
uh which are not due to be implemented
in until october
the reason i ask this is because i've
had concerns about
community safety effectiveness in the
past
and i'm wondering why uh this report
which is tabled to us today says we'll
actually have to wait until october when
these have been
going to be implemented and october's
next week
so i'm just wondering how ready we are
to implement those recommendations
thank you chad thank you that's enough
have we got an officer that could answer
that question
regarding safety would that be uh mr
holmes
yes chairman i think i can help um i can
offer reassurance that those um
uh have been looked at and are very much
well in progress if not um almost
completed so
i can give you assurance that it's been
looked at um work is underway and i say
the recommendations are very very much
worked on now thank
you very much chair okay thank you
um yes councillor channel
ask a question
uh thank you madam chairman um yes i was
gonna ask gonovering scrutiny but i'll
wait now because we haven't had that
report
um presented um so i will go to
um the one on page 27 to do with
this uh climate change uh strategy and
report
i'm not at medium risk or indicators
medium priority rather
i'm not quite clear then um when is this
anticipated it mentions
a draft report would go to strategy and
resources i'm not quite clear of the
time frame of this
um there's reference made to the others
but um unless i've missed it i couldn't
see when this is anticipated
and i'd quite like to know that having
attended the climate change commission
meeting
um only recently
that's the essex county council one by
the way but i attended with my malden
hat on
all right thank you cancer channel i
think mr holmes might be able to answer
that one
um i'm just going to ask if mr gillard
could pick up that uh answer because i
think obviously accompanied counselor
and he's actually the officer
responsible for drafting right so
perhaps he can help us
so yeah it's damien damien geller isn't
it yes i'll get that right this time
um go ahead okay so just to advise
um the climate change and environmental
strategy and the waste element of it as
well um
they there was a rough draft when when i
um
first joined around january time and we
agreed there was uh
more work and a larger scope to be taken
into account so we've pushed um
pushed that document back until around
december time for delivery now i'm
currently
working on the document as we speak in
terms of first off just to go around
internal partners
working towards that december deadline
so where i think council of china was
asking when it would go to strategy and
resources
uh it would be and you'll have to excuse
my migrants on the dates but it would be
uh whatever dates um happened around
december time for that
it'll be december time okay thank you
just to answer your question council
channel
thank you yes thank you thank you all
right members so there's no other
questions on those two reports we'll
move on to
um appendix three and four which is the
corporate governance audit and flooding
risk management
um is emma donnelly presenting those
yes i am thank you emma okay um i'll
start with the corporate governance
internal audit report that's page 29
and we in particular review of the
council's governance arrangements
and we conducted interviews with key
officers and also members to assess
operational effectiveness of the current
structures
and you'll notice we have issued a
moderate moderate report based on this
work
and we noted that the following and the
following transformation of the council
there have been revised committees
updated terms of reference and
frameworks established
schemes and delegation were updated and
reviewed in line with changes to
structures
the gifts and hospitality registers are
in place and they are being used
and the council's meeting all the
requirements transparency code
on the council's website in term term in
line with the public's right to know
we also find that there's been a review
of committee structures in line with the
redmond review
and that's been undertaken with proposed
changes due to be implemented this month
into your council committee makeup is in
line with best
and we've also known there's been
improvements in performance on
governance reporting with more work
being developed and underway at the
minute however we find
that um there's currently not a regular
governance regular governance oversight
at the pga
including review of internal service
kpis
and the corporate governance working
group will now be monitoring performance
via a new
internal balance scorecard on regards to
this
secondly we noted that the over overview
and scrutiny committee is not satisfying
its purpose in its terms of reference or
meeting rivalry
due to um not having um a business
established the corporate again the
corporate work governance working group
have considered this recommendation and
have recommended that the committee
continues
with training on the clear remit to be
established
thirdly we noted that member induction
programs have not been formalized to
support
refresher training or progression and we
note that the members onboarding
and process is also currently being
reviewed to support this recommendation
and finally we noted two low
recommendations
one around the annual performance
reviews of committees
and the fact that those um reviews not
been embedded within the terms of
reference
and this is being looked at to be
included and dependent on capacity of
officers
and also the scheme of delegation
requires a minor amendment which is
currently being refreshed
and if there's any questions firstly on
the corporate governance report
if not i can move on to flooding and
take them all at the end
okay well we'll take questions on
corporate governance i think
um councillor swain what's your question
on corporate governance
yes that's one of two points yes
um um i do echo counselor loves comment
about
skills but i think actually from the
auditor's point of view the case of
proof of the pudding is an eating
and if things haven't been done by
either pga
or overview and scrutiny and that is
the proof that things haven't been done
right and
things should have been picked up i
don't think there's any real
justification for the ovary and scrutiny
not having met
um i mean i can think of plenty of
things it should have been doing
um perhaps it should pick up the fact
and
the audit uh auditors perhaps sort of
picked up the point about
the way in which the recommendations on
committees and so on was handled
directly by council
and surely should have gone to
performance governance and audit
committee first
um i to my mind this is um and it's
going to come up in the other
section the other audit too it's an
instance of the
the working group not really reporting
as
such to the body that appoints it and
sets it up
and that i think is too opaque and is
not um informative enough for members
so this question about how working
groups
um uh report to the
to the bodies that set them up to me is
one of the issues
that overview and scrutiny should look
at um
i there probably will be further
discussion known
in uh committees on overview and
scrutiny
but it to my mind it has a quite
distinct function
um and it's not just a matter of i mean
it's been very much framed in the
context of an adversarial
cabinet like system and a political
opposition
um but the scrutiny issue
as was outlined by or in the guidance
from the
government last year is a more general
thing in which um
members should be involved um
right i think that's um my comment on
this particular audit
thank you chairman thank you thank you
um i think mainly they were just
comments rather than needing answers i
think we are
as we all know we have a statutory
annual on the 5th of november where
a lot of these um points that council
swain has made will be addressed
so um you know it's a different way
forward now so we hope the next
corporate governance audit will be a bit
nicer to us
um counselor none i think you wanted to
say something on corporate governance
yes i i come back chair to uh my point
about page 32
about uh skill base and i i don't
accept the response that i've had so far
um
in fact um i've got additional concerns
now that miss donnelly
has explained that she's interviewed
members uh
well i don't know who they were but they
i certainly haven't been interviewed and
i don't know
if anybody else has on ons and uh
on on this committee um but i can tell
you that the
the lack of meetings with ons
is not through lack of trying uh and
concern
on the part of some members so
you know i do hope that that changes but
my question for miss donnelly
is which members did she interview and
how has she arrived at the conclusion
that
members are not satisfactorily skilled
enough
you want to answer that one
sorry you're on the spot a bit but i'm
sorry i
i don't have the list of members that
were um
interviewed in front of me but i can i
can definitely get that information and
circulate it
but and we did work with the
corporate governance working group to to
meet with members
um i'm not sure anyone here on this call
where it was interviewed as part of the
audit
but i can circulate the list of people
that were and
in terms of the the finding around
members
training obviously that's um we would
look at that in terms of what our other
councils are doing and the fact that
there isn't a
formalized structure for refresher
training
or um additional training as members
might progress
would be something that we would look to
see that the council will be
implementing okay thank you
thank you thank you chair um thank you
for the answer
um but yes i would like to know who was
interviewed because if nobody
who's present here today was interviewed
that concerns me really you know how
representative for those interviews
and actually training and development
starts on the basis
of of the starting point of the skill
base of the individual
so you know i don't know how on earth we
know what skills people do and don't
have
so uh but thank you i'm happy to move on
thank you thank you councillor none um
but you know i'd repeat again we are
going to address things going forward as
from the statutory annual so
i'm sure of you and scrutiny will will
play a much
more active role after that
um councillor heard i think you wanted
to say something
on ons yeah thank you chairman uh
i think uh i think you may well have
answered uh answered my query uh yes i
have concerns
about um who was interviewed i mean as
leader of the opposition
i would have thought i'd have been a
prime candidate
to be interviewed indeed that's
something that i could have put
to the group i feel that the overview
and scrutiny committee has been scaled
down and down and down
so eventually they would say that there
was
no business i know that there was
business
and i think perhaps the terms of
reference need to be
revisited i welcome your comments
about a new way of working and i look
forward
and to doing that but i am concerned
that this report
um isn't giving um a fair cross-section
of those members who are on there thank
you
all right thank you thank you cancer
head um
so we'll go on if there's no more
questions on that one on corporate
governance we'll go on to flooding risk
right now
sorry bonus sorry i think cancer channel
and counselor jarvis had some cards
okay okay
think largely uh mine may have been uh
met madam chairman um but i i think i
did
register with great interest bearing in
mind some all i will say some comments
i've made in the past
um i think it was at corporate
governance about the performance of pga
and the kpis and i'm glad to see that
work will be done on those
uh because i do feel very much this
committee and i
i think possibly you share we do need to
have a greater oversight performance and
i think that has been pointed out now by
the report before us
so in a way it backs up perhaps my
feeling
yeah yes thank you council channel
councillor jarvis
yeah and thank you chairman um yes i
mean i know the two recommendations from
the governance report
the first one regarding service level
performance being challenged by pga on a
more regular basis
and that's welcome the other
recommendation pga should have an
increased level of oversight of
governance matters
i think this has been a common theme
throughout the year i've always been
very surprised as pga
that we've met so regularly and yet not
really had anything to talk about from a
government's point of view
and so it's it's it's slightly
disappointing that perhaps we have to
wait for an internal audit to tell us
what we probably should have known
already which is as a pga
committee we should obviously be looking
at governance issues on a regular basis
but look
the recommendation is that we're going
to get a more quarterly assessment of
governance issues
and those issues is going to come to
this committee and i think that is to be
welcome
what i would say though is i'd just like
to ask the question of officers
regarding
um the working group that exists uh
which is obviously reporting directly to
council on governance matters because i
certainly feel in a way that this
committee has been
slightly overlooked you know because the
recommendations from that working group
on governments have already gone to
council and then here we are as the
expert committee on governance
looking at the report after the event
and i'd certainly like to
hear if there are plans in motion to
have uh
we have for this committee this was
discussed at the last meeting but this
committee to have
appropriate uh working groups uh of
people
who who are on this committee to talk
about matters such as governments
i have to confess at this stage i was
interviewed i was one of those people
i i hope that uh um as somebody who
is professionally qualified in
governance i rather hope i haven't sort
of
diluted the uh professional standing of
of members i i'd like to think that's
not the case but
i was interviewed for the for the record
um but but i but i do think it's a great
shame i mean surely everybody
on this committee should have been
interviewed because this is the pga
committee
so if i'm the only one who's in was
interviewed that is that is uh
not ideal clearly but my general message
here is look if we are the pga committee
which includes governance which is a
serious issue yeah i don't believe
the working party made up of people who
aren't on this committee reporting to
council is the right arrangement
at all that committee should be
reporting uh that working group should
be reporting to this committee it should
be
this committee that has a working group
on governance and we would then work
very closely much more closely
with any internal audit on governance uh
to make sure that
we were all involved and we could then
trust and believe
uh in the outcomes of that report so
that would be my comment on the matter
sure
thank you okay thank you councillor
jarvis as you know we have
already raised this issue about the
corporate
governance working group and i hope that
we will
uh change the arrangement
for the future um i think someone has
got their hand
up but i can't see who it is do you know
benner
no no chairman
my chat is still not um live i'm afraid
is this about corporate governance
cancer
durham it's on the skills uh topic that
councilman
was mentioning i would just i i have to
say and it's rather a sad indictment
that
actually in nearly 10 years on this
authority nobody's ever asked me
what i've done in my business life what
qualifications i have
what outside professional bodies i
belong to
and and i have to say that member
development
has has been poor apart
from some uh initial training
um on on being elected
uh there's been very little so as i said
i i wasn't
um interviewed in this this particular
occasion nor have i been
uh in nearly ten years on this authority
and and i think that is
is uh as i said it's a sad indictment
and
should be corrected because members as
councillor none has pointed out
members have skills and if nobody knows
what those skills are we can't use
people to their best
advantage thank you all right good good
point
counselor durham um i believe councillor
heard wants to come back
on something counselor
yes thank you chairman um i may have to
i may have to eat my words i certainly
have
spoken to somebody about overview and
scrutiny but if
miss donnelly can provide me with the
dates um i will confirm that but that
that may have been
um that may have been another uh audit
away
from this but uh i wouldn't want to
mislead the committee thank you
okay thank you councillord um any other
people members that want to speak on
this item
if not we'll go on to flooding risk
management
audit emma please
yes and this is on page 47
and so we conducted a review of the
council's flood risk management
framework
and we've provided an assessment of
moderate moderate assurance
and we found that due to staff changes
the new lead officer for flood risks
had yet to undertake any relevant flood
training at the time of audit
however we note that the previous flood
lead has now returned to the council
on a temporary basis to support training
and this knowledge transfer
secondly we find that the strategic
flood protection plan and associated
actions
haven't been updated since 2018-19 at
work is now underway to update the flood
risk master plan
which is um due to be um reviewed at the
next coastal and flood risk group
meeting this month
and i'm not sure if that's already
happened or not yet um
thirdly no formal meetings on flooding
both internally and externally during
2020 have been conducted due to um
coveted 19. again work on this has also
resumed with the lead specialist for
community
working with parties to establish
meetings and
remotely and progress the plan
and fourthly the council did not have
clear guidance on rules and
responsibilities for
sustainable urban drainage systems this
again will be picked up through the new
flood risk strategy document
and on the the lead specialist
community might you have to write a bit
more information on the work that's
under undertaken on that
[Music]
okay thank you thank you think very
chana wants to come in on this one
council channel
i'm here sorry it's playing around with
my muting and everything
um yes on the report
and it was page 53 i'm doing it from
memory
you mentioned the flooding and coastal
group
hadn't met since december well
i've been in a recent flooding and
coastal group meeting
um only recently and i'm just wanting to
check that it's the same one that you're
talking about or is there more than one
and mr dodson who's here might be able
to uh throw some light on that
is the the one that's mentioned in the
report the one that i attended recently
and i thought i'd been in a earlier
meeting um
in the year as well so um i i just want
to check if it's one and the same
thank you thank you council channel i
think um mr geller damien gallagher can
answer that hello councillor
yes i would advise that is the same
meeting um basically
um at the time of the audit when when
the um
uh the draft and the checks were done
there had there wasn't um
a meeting that had taken place but as of
the um 15th of september
the first um coastal and flooding group
meeting did take place
so yes that's that's the meeting you're
referring to thank you
okay are you happy with that um council
chairman you know
the answer yeah um councillor swain i
think you had some question on flooding
yes thank you chairman um the first one
is this question about sars
expertise um we
do rely on
essex as a lead local flood authority
for
as the experts on says i'm not sure
whether
the auditor is advocating us having a
similar level of expertise
um in the district as well
um certainly on a similar quest similar
point really relating to flood risk
assessment
the big consideration of the risks
involved in fluvial
pluvial and tidal
risks is a very specific
specialist knowledge base
again is the auditor advocating that we
should have someone who is really
clued up in all of these areas
my third point concerns the action plans
which are
admittedly out of date and need to be
updated
with action plans does the
auditor um uh advocate that these plans
should include specific actions identify
who's responsible for carrying them out
and also
responsibilities for existing drainage
assets
thank you
emma do you want to answer that at all
um yeah i can start about deeming my
give to assist me further
and for the first two comments um i
guess or
our approach would be as long as the
council can
provide assurance that they're they have
the support there from ethics and
and they are able to i guess demonstrate
that those risks have been mitigated
through
through working with essex county
council and then that would satisfy
i guess our requirements in terms of
what we would expect to see so as long
as they're able to demonstrate that they
have
access to that and that level of
specialism
through that mechanism i can confirm
that's that's the case we have
quite strong uh working relationships
with s6 and in fact we're waiting for
uh follow-up reports in relation to a
number of different schemes
um so that we can basically work with
them to make sure those schemes are
carried out
and also keep tabs on existing schemes
as they're moving forward now
some of that work was um if you like
stalled by some of the coded stuff but
it's now started to come back online
thank you damian um as we know the
lead flood authority is essex county
council
officers so i hope that you have
a person that you can liaise with on
this
rather than various different people
at the county have you got a pacific
person that you ref
you always liaise with yes counselor
we do so um i tie in quite closely with
dave chapman
um who provides me with a lot of um
advice and updates
um and also who who's going to be the
main contact in terms of getting the
essex report back to us and working with
us in terms of how we take those things
forward
okay thank you very much that answer
sorry i just thought to come back on the
point about
how specific the um any action plan
coming out of this
would be in tying down responsibilities
including responsibilities for existing
drainage systems
right so at the level of um the audit
um there's various actions within the
audit and
my details are against those so i'm the
officer that's responsible for
monitoring performance
against those those actions when we
start looking at the individual plans
um they they are split
differently between different offices so
there's some bits that i will i will
have specific control over there's
others that um
sit with other officers in the council
um
what my intention is to do is as we
start to update some of our documents
with particular regard to the
uh the flood uh master master plan flood
risk master plan
would be to try and um include officers
names against that plan so we know who's
leading on what so that's already
in there it just needs updating and
sharpening
[Music]
thank you thank you um does that answer
your question or was it in relation to
perhaps management companies set up on
the
various major sites
was it in relation to that because i
know that the suds will come under some
of those management companies
it is another aspect of tying down
responsibilities
for assets yes yeah okay
thank you very much um thank you damian
i think council channel wanted to come
back on something please
madam chairman um just just a question
so i understand
something really page 58 and it talks
about
field work and the lead officer again it
mentioned shirley hall
um as well now i think it's
now damien so i'm just trying to work
out bearing in mind the length of time
that shirley halls left
the authority um why
perhaps that officer's name is still
shown um
why perhaps um it wasn't corrected i'm
not making a
an issue out of this but it's a bit
confusing when you see that
when in fact we've had another officer
in situ who appears to be doing this i
think the report ought to reflect
the correct names really because the
next question i'll be asking about the
field work has it commenced and when i
read the text it doesn't appear as
though it has
so i think it's quite important so we're
clear who has got that responsibility
within the authority and not have
the names of someone who left actually
several months ago
thank you i don't know whether you want
to come back on that emma just to
explain
um i guess that there she probably
should have been updated but
whenever the terms of reference were
initially issued um
shirley was the the lead on that but it
should have been updated to reflect that
damian's not imposed
okay thank you vernon have we got any
other are you happy with that council
channel
uh yes madam chairman berna have we got
any other
people that want to speak on this no not
seeing anyone else
well i'm sorry cancer dom has his hand
up but i it may be a legacy
and i'm not quite sure counselor durham
did you want to speak on flood risk
no i i have been trying to get my hand
down i think you'll find it
yeah yeah okay so um committee
we have the we have made lots of
comments on these reports
um so the recommendation was that we do
that
consider comment and improve um
so are we happy to do that
can i just have a like yesterday
yes agreed yes i don't think we need to
take a problem
with that one we agree well chairman
could i ask that then the comments we've
made in the actions
um yeah they'll be clearly recorded so
we know actions will come out of our
comments and
and stuff well i would hope so i mean we
will make sure the minutes reflect that
um and going forward perhaps we need
some kind of follow-up on the actions
which i'll discuss with the clerks and
um the officers
thank you all right chairman we're
agreeing that by ascent
yes yeah we are agreeing it by a certain
brother thank you thank you
um so the next item is ext
external audit fees report
for 2019-20 um
pound on pages 61-68
um so we have um mr wisdom
craig wisdom here i think to present
this report please
um chair i i um i wasn't going to say
anything
specific on it because um paper that um
i think covers the discussion certainly
that we've had
um both in the lead up to and uh in
the discussion of that so i'm happy to
just take questions okay
thank you well just to let let you know
members that counselor jarvis and myself
have had discussions with mr wisdom
prior
to this report being produced
and the fee has been
considerably reduced as a result
so can i take questions berna
have we uh counsellor heard your
flashing does that mean you
counseling nan has indicated
none thank you very much chairman and
i'm grateful to you
and councillor jarvis for uh negotiating
a reduction
it's nevertheless still 54 762 pounds
um and this is not really a question for
mr wisdom
it's uh a broader question for the
officers
about have we benchmarked the audit fee
uh with other comparable size local
authorities
and have we benchmarked the fee with
other audit providers
thank you i think the answer to that is
yes um council number
mr wisdom do you want to just confirm
shall i take that question yeah
okay mr leslie then sorry
i think the answer is yes uh we have
benchmarked
across ethics and uh we are seeing uh
some sort of uh fees obviously will vary
from council to council for various
reasons
and there are different uh suppliers uh
across
those different councils so we've only
taken the councils
uh close to us and doing a sample
with those uh they do cover other audit
firms as well and a little about a bit
about the process
uh perhaps it is um touched on in the
report
but it does include the uh the psaa you
will see
in there and they will have the ultimate
say
uh around fees uh as well as a bit of
discussion
about that in there so the answer is yes
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you chad
um is there anyone else benner who wants
to speak no chairman
um counselor heard your
your picture is flashing does that mean
you want to speak
um no tim um no sorry
all right okay so the recommendation as
is that the contents of this report be
noted
um i have a second after that
second day yes okay and everyone is
happy with that
thank you yeah yeah
okay so we've uh agreed that by ascent
and burner thank you
um so the next item
is item eight external audit update
2019-20
found on pages 69-94
um so again if you want to speak please
use the chat
function um so mr wisdom
you want to speak on this one yes uh
yes thank you chairman so i'll just draw
out the
the key observations if i may um
in terms of the status of our orbit it
is nearing completion
and with the exception of some work
related to asset valuations and the
pension liability
both of which are touch ons just now the
remaining work is related to our normal
finalization
procedures the scope of our work has
remained broadly in line with what we
described in our
plan that you saw in july there were
however
two key impacts um the first was that we
elevated the risk around the valuation
of property plant and equipment and
investment property
uh from an area of focus to a
significant risk
and that was due to areas that we
identified
uh in the course of our work in the
current year uh in combination with
areas that we have also identified in
the previous years
uh again i'll touch on on a little bit
later
the second area of impact was due to
covet 19.
we have included a summary of that
impact which you can see on pages
76 to 78 of the pack and also
that also includes how you responded the
impact on the oracles both
in terms of the accounts as well as the
actual
practical delivery of the audit uh so in
terms of the accounts the key impact
areas and you'll see this when
when you're approved upon accounts with
that additional narrative reporting and
disclosures were needed in the accounts
um so there were there were a number of
areas but a couple of examples of the
more prominent ones would be the
disclosures
uh actually describing the impact of
covert on the council
and also the disclosures around critical
judgments
in the accounts and policies another key
area
are the impact on the valuation of
property plant and equipment to
investment properties
where there is a material uncertainty
over the valuation
i'll discuss that in a little bit more
detail when i talk about the significant
risky areas
now another area is the valuation of the
pension fund
both from an assumptions and asset
perspective and the final
area really that i pull out was in
relation to the expected critical losses
for us that's accounted for
and uh for s9 so that's international
financial reporting
and on the delivery side uh your team
had to prepare moki and we had to
deliver the audit remotely
uh which was which was challenging but
um
we we used technology and project
management tools extensively
uh to manage this and uh you know
reflecting on it i think
um that it went
if i just touch briefly on each of the
significant risk areas these are on
pages 79 to 81 of the pack
the first one is management override
controls this is an assumed risk under
international auction standards
and one that we have on every audit that
we do the focus of our work is on key
areas of estimating judgment
along with looking for inappropriate
journals
our work in this area was satisfactory
although we did identify
it did identify a control recommendation
which uh
which i've noted
the second area is valuation of property
assets
so we focus on this because there's a
lot of judgment involved
there are probably there are two things
i'd like to pull out the first is
as i mentioned um just now there is
additional complexity that's been added
due to covert and that has led to your
value
including a material uncertainty course
and the valuation information that they
provided to you
uh the clause was included because of
the volatility
uh in the markets at the time um at the
time of year in which was the 31st of
march
so for example it was it was difficult
to judge what
would happen to things like build costs
of specialized assets uh
for non-specialized assets there was no
real comparable market information
for the situation which was created one
pandemic
the material uncertainty i referred to
is disclosed in your accounts
and i also refer to it in my author's
opinion but a couple of specific things
on that material uncertainty
one is that this is a common clause
that's been added by valuers
across the public sector valuations
so there's nothing unusual about the the
clause that's been added to moldon's
valuations
the second thing to to just add is that
although i refer to it in my opinion
this is not a qualification or a
modification of my opinion
so i'm just drawing attention to it uh
the second thing i want to pull out on
property around the property work that
we did
was that during our testing we did
notice
we did not identify material errors
and i referred to those earlier which is
a reason why we escalated it to a
significant risk
the actual the actual areas that we
identify are summarized in the deloitte
view box on page 80
uh of the pack and because of the areas
that we
identified we have had to extend the
work that we've done that we've had to
do in this area to be satisfied that
there are no
further material errors so that that
additional work that we're um
that we're doing at the moment is still
in progress and we are hoping to
finalize that in the coming weeks
uh the final sort of specific area that
i want to
touch on whilst not a significant risk
it is an area of
focus and that's pensions as i said
earlier
this is also an area that's impacted by
the volatility caused by
by covert we do focus on both the the
asset side of the
the pension liability as well as the
actuarial assumptions that go into the
the liability our work in the series is
uh is almost complete and we're in the
final stages of
just assessing the income the final bits
of information that have come back from
the actuaries
as well as the pension scheme auditors
so justify move on now to the work on
the arrangements to secure economy
efficiency and effectiveness
of the council's use of resources which
is on page 83 of the pack
uh just a reminder that i'm i'm required
to consider the arrangements that are in
place and not whether the council has
achieved good use of resources at all
times
i also conclude on the arrangements um
but we do focus on working on things on
certain areas like for example and
financial sustainability
uh through the course of the work uh i
didn't identify any significant
risks and so therefore there weren't any
areas that i
that i investigated in further detail
just before i move on to my final
conclusion i'd like to touch briefly on
our control findings
these are included on pages 86 and 87 of
the pack
with the main recommendation being in
respect of the property evaluations
i'd also like to add that we have
followed up on our recommendations that
we made
last year and that the council has made
good progress on addressing those
recommendations
um which i think is reflected in the
fact that
the bulk of the order worked that that
was complete
so there are a couple of things that
have delayed us finalizing but
but actually we probably got 19 1995
percent of the work done
uh by the first or second week of july
which was which was the original plan
which is a very good effort um i'd like
to close if i may uh
thank you to kristen james and the
finance team who i think have
have pulled together the financial
statements and working papers to a good
standard
uh particularly given the challenges of
last year um and also the challenges
that
um came about as a result of having to
do remote working and
and and frankly the operational
challenges that came from uh operating
to um pandemic so chairman i'd like to
close
my comments there and i'm happy to take
questions
well thank you very much mr wisdom that
was very comprehensive
um analysis of your report and
thank you for for uh thanking our
officers who have worked very hard
on this so thank you from me as well to
our offices
and to yourself mr wisdom um have we got
um anyone i think um counselor channel
would like to speak is there anyone else
nobody else at the moment okay counselor
channel
okay thank you uh madam chairman it's uh
to do with paige
um if i can find it 78 now if i may
um it's appendix one and it says covered
related income received and it's
referenced to the 1.6 billion
um the first tranche passed out to
councils by um
mch lg and it says what the council did
and i said we note aft that after
discussion and reference to guidance
these have been treated correctly in the
updated statement of accounts
can you just sort of explain a bit
behind that i think it's obviously
linking with the grant and young
ring fencing and everything you refer to
but can you just explain what correction
was required please
we're just playing with the mute button
um so it was um
it was what we were talking about there
is
because it was a ring fence grant it was
required to be booked
as within the current year accounts
rather than the third
so that's that's it's as simple as that
really it wasn't um
it was a judgmental area and there
wasn't anything
significant
right so just so i'm clear the grant was
on ring fence and that without
conditions
are you saying that is what government
said or what you're relating to malden
no the the the letter actually the
letter that
came with the grant uh said it was under
influence and because it's something
defense that's what drives the account
and treatment
okay right it was a it was a government
uh it was the
that came from government rather than
our uh malden's decision or
yeah okay that's how i read it i just
wanted to make sure that was my reading
of it
uh but i was interested to know when you
said that in reference to guidance
um they've been treated correctly in the
updated statements
yeah okay that's where i think um i just
wanted to seek the um
clarity there as as well because um
you know it could be misinterpreted well
i did to a degree but it
that's made it much clearer for me thank
you
okay thank you councillor channel um
anyone else want to
ask any questions berna no nobody's
indicated no one else
okay so members the recommendation is
that we
note the contents of the report have i
got a seconder to that please
second noted note i don't know
everyone is happy with just agreeing a
cent on that one
yes
so the next item on the agenda is
quarterly review
of corporate risk um
found on pages 95-104
um so we've got um miss hughes to
present this report
so if i can ask miss hughes to present
the report please
um good afternoon members so uh this
report deals with quarter one risk which
covers
april june 2020 um in summary for the
changes since
quarter four there are two risks that
have seen a decrease in score and these
are
r17 which is failure to maximize
services through promotion and
engagement
and r29 failure to deliver services
as a result of covid and this
r29 was added as the pandemic hit but
by june clt had a better view on the
service impact so that's why it's
um seen a decrease and there are two
risks that have been recommended for
closure and
one um r22 around contract management
and that's recommended for closure as
the
monitoring steps are now in place um
r17 around promotion and engagement um
further to the update that i gave above
just that we've actually got
um a promotion and engagement sort of
formalized now
there are three risks that have seen an
increase in score
and these are around the five-year
housing land supply
around meeting affordable housing need
and around
creating jobs to support the growing
population
these have all seen an increase due to
the wider impacts of the current
pandemic
clt continue to regularly monitor and
review the risks given the emergency
pandemic measures
and at an operational level we now have
the additional level of the balanced
scorecard to report
and monitor risks that have been removed
from this corporate register
and so that we can escalate them back up
should the controls no longer be working
so for example with the contract
management um the monitoring for that
will now take place within the balanced
scorecard
and we will be able to report back up
should the risk escalate
and thank you okay thank you
um berna have we got members that wish
to ask a question
yes counseling nun and then council
swain
okay counselor none thank you very much
chairman
and thank you for the report um cheryl
um
can i take you please to page 101
uh and risk r14
which is around the human resource
and it's about recruitment and retention
and it says that the risk is unchanged
and it gives it as a three by three
which unless i'm mistaken uh says it's a
moderate risk
does that mean then that in this latest
report
that the turnover rate is the same
turnover rate that we had at the
previous
report and if so what is the turnover
please
choose could you answer that yeah
so that risk actually isn't um monitored
by turnover rate that's specific
to um specific skill sets so and that's
to do with
um difficulty to recruit roles like
planners
um so the reason that that risk is
unchanged is just that there are still
some
um positions that have been difficult to
recruit to and so the
risk that we're carrying remains the
same on that one um
regards turnover i'm not sure um of
these specific figures but they are
being monitored in their hr dashboard at
the moment
um so coming back uh through you chair
retention and recruitment is turnover
and so
are you carrying the same number of
vacancies in those specialist areas
or have you had the same number of
levers and new starters in those areas
excuse me so i'm not sure if richard
wants to provide more specific
information
and because obviously this relates to
his area
and but i believe it's due to the
specific positions that were already
flagged
still being vacant
mr holmes did you want to come in on
that yes i i obviously haven't got the
information immediately my fingertips in
terms of turnover i'm happy to supply
that to the committee
um uh in writing after this meeting but
um i think
misuse is correct you obviously track a
number of jobs um
i think we reflected yesterday i think
we've got about 16 new starters
that come to the authority during kobit
so they've actually started working for
us virtually so there is a
and always an ebb and flow of staff and
but i can get you the uh the details um
for the turnovers separately that would
help you thank you that would be
helpful thank you are you happy with
that
if it helps um richard i'm not
particularly
probing uh deeply the turnover issue i'm
just trying to work
out whether we're carrying specialist
vacancies still or we've got people
coming to us or have we got more
specialists leaving
now i know any in any organization
turnover is not a bad
thing but it but it is if it's excessive
and it is if we're not filling the posts
that's that's all i'm
all i'm trying to bottom out is are we
carrying specialist
um uh gaps okay that's helpful for that
clarification i can certainly um give
you the detail you're looking for now
thank you thank you very much mr times
thank you okay anyone else got questions
counselor swain and councillor channel
okay council swain
um yes thank you gentlemen um in
relation to
r9 and r10 um which are both really
concerned with
the economic situation um in the
district
um and quite pessimistic on the back of
kovid
but i would uh just express there is
some
optimism in that with the
great increase in distance working
and the scope for small businesses plus
the attraction of the area
there is um an area there for
promoting um the district and in view of
what's said about
um as we say lack of a county-wide
promotion approach
i wonder whether um we should be
uh considering say going our own way in
terms of promoting the district
to some extent um the other point is uh
bringing in developments related to brb
i think it's
um what should we say it's a totally
different time scale
anything related to brb support
or skills in relation to trying to um
improve inward investment and so on in
the next year or two
my second point concerns are eight
on the first page um
i think the relationship of the south
malden relief road
to um development of strategic sites is
is the wrong way around um
the it's not that the relief is going to
affect this development it's rather that
the development of the strategy
sites affects decisions on whether it be
a south modern relief road so i don't
think that is
a break on on development
of far greater importance um
for uh the future of um particularly the
developing
or supposed development of north
haybirds garden suburb
is what happens to the junction on the
a12
getting to the a12 thank you
thank you cancer swain um mr johnson did
you want to come in on that on
some of those questions yes thank you
chairman
um regarding the promotion of the
district
i i think councillor swain's right there
are opportunities
um as well as issues that arise from the
um coveted emergency and it's something
we're actively looking at is how we
uh maximize the recovery of the district
and um promote the opportunities that
come from that in terms of
uh location of business etc as we come
out of that so yes that's something
um we're looking at in terms of the
the second point regarding r8
um i think at the the point that the
report was written
the members had actually refused the
permission
for one of the um
provisionally through through the first
meeting permission for one of the
um strategic sites within the the south
molden philly garden suburb
subsequently that was approved but
obviously if that hadn't come forward
all of the affordable housing within
that wouldn't have come forward and that
would have had a direct
impact so that was mainly what that
related to
um and the the road itself was was
almost a secondary issue
to that but it was the that the site
wasn't coming forward
at the time thank you
can't just wait are you happy with that
yes sir just thank you
thank you i know we got anyone else that
was just this week
that's a channel yeah that's the channel
sorry chairman
before i'm sorry council channel i cut
i'm unable to raise
or get on to chat so if you could put me
on your list at the moment okay
all right well we'll ask you after
councillor channel
in a way it's been answered now because
councillor swains referred to r8 which
is on page 99 which i was
and it does say quarter one um but the
reports here now
and we're sitting near towards the end
of september
um and actually um i just asked why the
report wasn't necessarily updated with
members having approved
the planning application because i think
i seem to recollect actually
although i couldn't sit on it for
various reasons that committee when it
sat
was done in pretty swift succession so i
just wondered
why when did quarter one end because i'm
sure
quarter two would make it accurate but i
would i thought because of the close
succession of the refusal and approval
perhaps the report could have been
updated because otherwise i think it can
create a bit of confusion
um that's just perhaps a comment but i
would like to know
um when the quarter one specifically
ended and why the approval which i
thought was
very swift on behalf following on from
the refusal
um couldn't have been implanted in the
report chairman
thank you council chairman mrs do you
want to answer that one
so quarter two ends at the end of
september
which is why you're seeing quarter one
report at the moment it's just because
of the way that the
timing falls with the reporting coming
forwards so this covers
till the end of june so it would have
factored in the decision that was made
until the end of june
right are you happy with that cancer
channel well
was it an old farm application because
it was i thought the refusal and the
approval fellow
went pretty swiftly maybe i'm
recollecting incorrectly
if if i could add that absolutely
the they may have been closed together
but it
certainly wasn't within the first
quarter um when the final
um decision to approve was made hence
i can't remember the exact date i can
obviously check that
for you counselor channel but from
memory that did fall outside of the the
first quarter hence the reason why the
report is as it is
um okay okay okay with that council
channel yes i am it might be because i
think
there was one fairly recently which
seemed to be hinging more to do with the
road even
um well i'll yeah okay i'll wait till i
get the uh
answer from the information rather
thanks
okay thank you council china councillor
durham
yes thank you sorry yes that seems to be
falling over this afternoon
um i just would really wanted to respond
to it to comment councillor swain
has made um in my uh county role
i'm also um uh
i'm also chair of visit essex and for
his benefit
the visit ethics are just about to
embark on a
fairly significant promotional uh
promotional activity
concentrating on the aesthetics
coastline and clearly um
uh you know clearly morgan will feature
fairly heavily in that we're very
mindful of the
the issues that the malden district has
so
uh he can rest assured that uh from the
county and visit essex perspective we're
doing all we can to to help promote
malden and all we have
well that is great to hear councillor
john
um we've got councillor heard
have we or councillor swain i think
wanted to come in again
counts this way and is it in relation to
the um
planning application query um it's just
very briefly to say if in view of the to
say the updating aspect of
r8 um what would the risk of
falling back to
at the moment i don't
have that to hand at the moment but
obviously that will be reported at the
next committee
um i can provide that offline or it will
come to the next committee well i i
think um
council swain if we can wait for the
next committee in the next uh
quarters report that would probably help
you
thank you very much uh councillor heard
um thank you jen and i was just
proffering the date i think it was the
20th of august
okay thank you thank you for that um
i'm sure miss hughes will make a note
and follow that up for us thank you
uh anyone else wanting to speak on
corporate risk
no one else well we had the full
recommendations um noting the scoring
um commenting and reviewing
any of the corporate risk scores
so members we're happy with the scores
that are
that the clt have put in the risk report
um so if we are could i have a seconder
to those four
recommendations happy chairman
thank you durham um is everyone on the
committee happy
to uh agree that rather than taking a
vote
yes okay so
we've agreed that by a sent then berna
thank you thank you
uh and the next agenda is quarterly
quarter one review of corporate
performance
which is on pages 105 to 126
and again we've got miss hughes to
present this report
again there are three recommendations
um for us to comment on to see if it's
being managed
effectively um
and um we need to think about the report
to strategy and resources
um setting out the recommendation
changes in life impacts on outcome
performance including covid
so i'll go to miss hughes please thank
you okay
um so members the quarter one
performance report again
covers april to june 2020 and you'll see
from the report that work is largely on
track and the outcomes are being
delivered
um but from some of the comments um the
way that we thought we would deliver
things has changed and activity has
sometimes been
diverted largely due to the impact of
covid
and you'll see in section 3.3 of the
covering report there's a summary table
that highlights for each of the three
themes
the number of measures that are either
on track or otherwise
and this follows feedback at previous
committee meetings to give that high
level view
section 3.4 specifically draws out the
areas at risk by theme in part
these are in large part impacted by
covid and they are
for the community strategy the customer
evaluations
survey for the private sector housing
grants
um the molden district council um
digital services assistance um
the community weight management sessions
and for place the local volunteering
activity
uh keeping britain tidy green flag award
and um the 2019
strategic flood projects and maintenance
plan
and for prosperity the percentage of
strategic sites promoted through
partners
and the occupancy at the enterprise hub
however some of the new activity that's
been taking place
where resources have been diverted has
included things like
virtual fitness campaigns grow your own
vegetables
and direct engagement with those in
isolation
risk groups for covid which far
surpasses the original target number for
people we expected to reach
an increase in channel shift as a result
of
the way that we've shifted to online
services
uh volunteering activity being used for
open spaces has been redeployed
for the covid response and we've had
conversation with 80 businesses
in the high street as part of the covid
response
so in light of this there is an
additional recommendation this time for
a review of the corporate plan
and the targets to go to strategy and
resources committee
and to reflect that there's a bit of a
changing landscape
and that it's had an impact on those
outcome measures
thank you members
thank you um could you just tell me what
when
that is likely to you be going to
corporate
uh strategy and resources this corporate
um
the changes that you're talking about
that you're we're recommending from this
committee to prepare a report for the
strategy and resources
so that report is proposed to go to
which meeting of strategy and resources
if i could answer that um yes thank you
mr dos
yes i think um either even since we we
drafted this report
we're we're going to have a possibly a
more significant review of the
corporate plan um because of all of the
changing conditions
that we've had um we're doing some work
on it and have put together a project
plan to do some work
um through october and into november
then i would envisage that potentially
following
um statutory annual council we'll do a
workshop with members to present that
work
and then subsequently at the the
following strategy and resources
committee
will take the the initial report then
so um i've not got the the dates in
front of me
but um it would the timeline would seem
to be december
um to get that through um
i can check that and and i'm just trying
to clarify
um mr johnson exactly what you're
expecting this committee to
do in in this recommendation
to preparing this report i i think
really it's
it's just recognizing the the impact of
the
the covid emergency and endorsing the
fact that we need to to undertake that
review
which then we will take through strategy
and resources
as the appropriate route in developing
the the corporate plan
okay all right um thank you
so um burner do we have any
any member that wishes to ask some
questions uh caster swain
check mr spain
um thank you and chairman um several on
uh
place and prosperity um firstly on the
um page 116 um
about waste um and i think this has
cropped up
before um can we have incorporated in
this
some information some data about
um uh waste um
recycling uh at the uh is that the
council um tip um to incorporate and
combine with
um uh purely district council
related statistics secondly there are
several
areas that are mentioned relating to
housing but i
guess anything there is rather up in the
air at the moment
but because of the government's attitude
on or the government's new
plans on housing or possible
developments
um
yeah the
um on place outcomes i think it comes
back to the point i was making earlier
about
reporting to committees by my workshops
on place supporting plans
page one two one um
it mentions the should modern district
this uk more than uh
2019 strategic flood projects the
maintenance plan
um where is that plan that one can
can inspect please
and then on prosperity outcomes um i
it raises this point about um
how much we can do or
expect to do in relation to um
preparation for brb
and then there's a mention of um the
place
board can you say who are the place
board um and uh
do they report to any committee
lastly on one two five
about um uh tourism promotion
um you mentioned that um some additional
material is between put online about
walking and cycling
um do you have any plans to
produce more information about the
district
that previously perhaps the tourist
information center might have had
thank you very much thank
i think mr holmes was wanting to answer
some of those
uh thank you chairman i'll just pick up
on a couple of points regarding waste
um as you've correctly identified that
is an essex county council facility and
which obviously they are responsible for
for operating
um so i will approach this county
council to see if we can get some data
that aligns with our timeline
um so that you can actually make a
comparison but it is a self-contained
unit which um obviously the county
council
are responsible for um the operation of
an and disposal of all the materials
that um go through that
um the flood plan i'll have to come back
to members with the exact location for
that
um i suspect it is shared on an eye
drive but uh i need to give you the
exact location for it so um i will
circulate that after the meeting thank
you
and the other question was about place
is that something you can answer
mr holmes i'm sorry mr johnson
yeah i'm happy to answer that one the
the place board um
relates to the sense of place board so
the sense of place initiative
which is a business led initiative which
the the council
was also part of in um developing
um must be around five years ago now
that it started
as it's an independent initiative it
doesn't report
directly to um a council committee
um the the council sits on the board and
is represented
uh through the chair of the strategy and
resources
committee as the member on the board
and the
any projects that go forward to the
board
that relate to the um council itself
will be
subject to going through committee for
any endorsement so if there's
um financial contributions for example
to any of those projects
that are in the center place action plan
then they would be
obviously subject to council committee
in that way
thank you um i think council swain would
have liked to have known where
perhaps he might see those um notes from
the meeting even though it's an outside
board
if we've got representation from s r
um is there any way that those notes
of meetings can be seen those notes of
meetings where we're
going to i'm not going to say that
they're directly available now because
i'm sure if i do they
they won't be but we're looking to make
sure they're available on the library on
modgov to make sure that there's
feedback from those external groups
there
okay thank you it's that answer all your
questions counselors wayne i'm not sure
if
all of them were um addressed
so the others were just comments really
but
i i certainly hope that mr holmes can
direct me to the um
flood projects and maintenance yes yes i
think okay thank you
thank you um counselor channel i think
wanted to speak
thank you madam chairman i'm just going
to hopefully find it
um yes it goes back actually to an
earlier report to do with the audit
and we heard about the climate change
strategy
and damien gallachine advised us when
that work was anticipated
um however on what i did notice was on
this report appendix one um page one two
one it does say
target is to submit draft strategy to
committee by november 2020
and i think mr geller advised it'd be
december 2020.
so has there been some slippage um and
it will be december now or is this
um the target and it will actually have
to be november
because the the two don't quite tally i
appreciate this information given in the
meeting but
just uh i thought i would raise that
point so we're clear when it can be
chairman if anticipated could help i
think we should stick within the uh
december
uh date i think uh obviously there are
other uh pressing priorities for mr
at the moment regarding kobit as well so
i'm conscious of his workload so i would
i would first stick to that he indicated
in december if that's possible please
okay thank you um anyone else berna who
wants to speak
no chairman no okay so
members we have the three
recommendations
one reviewing the information i think
we've done that
um the second one to make sure the
corporate performance is being managed
effectively and the third one which i'm
really
not 100 sure on what we need to do here
that members ask officers to prepare a
report for the strategy and resources
committee
setting out any recommended changes
in light of impacts on outcome
performance
including covet
i'm not quite clear on that um mr dodson
as to why this committee has to do that
no um unless someone else on the
committee can throw some light on why
that would be the case
if i if i can can answer that chairman
that this committee
[Music]
officers don't need the permission of
this committee
to to undertake that work um
but but at the same time
it underlines the need for it and
reflects the changing conditions that
that we've seen
through um kovid and the the performance
issues that that have arisen through
that
and just endorses that approach that
members are taking
to take that work through strategy and
resources but
technically yes it doesn't need that
instruction from from this committee to
do that
i don't think i don't think we need to
do that really
um so can we remove that because i don't
think we really need to do that here
i wouldn't have thought so i don't think
it was on the agenda meeting i don't
recall it um
i don't know whether mr councillor
jarvis is still here i don't know
whether he remembers this
at the agenda meeting um
but i i don't i don't see why we should
have to
do that at all um if you have got to
prepare a report for strategy and
resources
in light of performance on um that's
been affected by covid um
which may affect the corporate plan
that's what you're indicating is it
isn't it um then why would any of that
come through this committee i
don't i know it's performance indicators
but we're only checking
that we're happy with the performance
and the way that the council are
dealing with it i don't think we're
needing to recommend anything to
strategy and resources
so i don't really want to um agree that
recommendation i'm sorry i think
chairman
it's um i think it was just sort of
courtesy not as the sort of
committee that we are responsible for
performance
because a lot of the performance issues
relate to kobe
um i follow the logic that we're looking
at performance
because of those changes and quite
serious changes in performance
it would be not unreasonable for this
committee to be encouraging
as officers are indicating for the
strategic committee and to be having
another look at the plan
which needs to change um i think it's a
matter of um
uh it seems very common sense to me i
mean i don't think it's a big issue but
i think as a committee we should be
happy to endorse that the corporate plan
is looked at because performance
issues are changing significantly
because of code i don't think it's any
more
or any less than that if i've
interpreted that right in terms of the
top
right yeah i think it's just the wording
of it probably that
makes it sound as though you know it's
something that we're insisting upon
we're not giving anybody an instruction
we're happy to endorse that i think is
what we're being asked to do as the
performance committee
well could we amend the wording um
please
um berna to say that members
of this committee endorse um
the officers preparing a report
rather than asking yes
german no problem are you happy with
that members
what do you think council channel well
could it reference something about the
corporate plan and if that's what the
essence of that is really about
yes because that makes sense to me then
because i'm just thinking and remember
the public reading it
it's not quite clear really so
i think it might be helpful because i
must admit i looked at that
and actually i think it's it's good to
change the wording i'm not saying i have
a problem with
the um principle of what the officers
are seeking but i think
make it clearer that is about the you
know so it's going to strategic
resources and of course we know what
their remit is so it gets that linkage
clear
about why officers are seeking that and
yeah
you know i think the wording you've just
applied is good but i think it should
make some reference about the corporate
plan
yeah because that's really what it's the
basis of so we could and
add on the end and the effects um
and how it affects the corporate plan
yeah or in relation to this corporation
or something
in relation to it yeah in relation to
the government
yeah we're doing endorse instead of ask
and
um in relation to the corporate plan
at the end after covet 19.
is that clear but yeah and if that's
what mr dodson was meaning
or whoever who wrote the report if
they're happy with that
then yeah are officers happy with that
change
i'm happy with that approach yes thank
you members okay thank you very much
okay
thank you councillor jarvis for
clarifying that
um my brain is not functioning terribly
well at the moment as you can probably
hear um so are we happy to second then
members those three points on the
recommendations
agreed
agreed yeah so we agree agreeing those
aren't honest
um all agree i agree
right the next item is any other items
of business that the chairman of the
committee decides are urgent
um i don't have any um so
we will then close the meeting
at um 14
41. and thank you very much everyone
thank you